do you feel like uh
for you obviously
you know
having because i saw the otf logo on the
back of your track track listen are you
like officially
an otf artist you know you know you know
dirk that's my mentor you feel me yeah
so
it's just like really blood was just
trying to get behind me on some
anything i could do to help anything i
could do to help whatever you need you
need to do like i'm behind you 100 types
if you understand so
we partnering up on a lot of stuff
that's dope you know what is some of the
game that you know he you know i think
some people forget how long dirk's been
at this
blood i always tell me like stay
consistent like stay in the studio
whatever you got to do go do that [ __ ]
and then come back to the studio stay
consistent it's a new artist everyday
out here you feel what i'm saying yeah
you can't let them forget about you you
know yeah
always be different i'll never do these
[ __ ] out here doing just do yourself
and be different yeah yeah that's crazy
yeah no i feel like he's right i mean i
think dirk's
he went through a a couple of errors of
music
and a couple of errors in his career
where he was like on def jam they were
trying to have a blood got real live
years of experiencing this [ __ ] on a lot
of levels for